[Música]
[Aplausos]
olá
bom eu sou pai de duas crianças mais
velhas têm oito anos mais nova tem sido
no natal eu pedi que todas as pessoas
que comumente presenteiam seus filhos um
tio x amigos a voz presente assim com
jogos de tabuleiro
a nota não estavam muito ligadas a jogos
de celular
a mobilidade traz um pouco isso né
basta jogar bem em qualquer lugar em
qualquer tempo causando ou não
inconveniente para os pais por causa do
convênio conveniência é e surpreso
quando eles receberam os presentes e
sentaram ao chão abriram tocaram
sentiram eu senti uma leve esperança de
que o também central chão eles me
diverti era vir competir discutir o meu
filho fez a primeira é o pai e agora a
gente vai fazer para jogar disse
agora a gente vai ler o manual de
instrução eu juro que eu fui mais
natural possível
mas mais natural ele foi ele que me
perguntou manual de instrução rappa jogo
ronaldo é um jogo como educador
eu percebi mundo digital é a realidade
dele assim como muitos jovens que o
trabalho
esse mundo essa transformação uso das
novas tecnologias
eles se eu quiser algum dia convencê lo
de usar alguma nova experiência didática
exista em outros jogos eu não posso rodá
lo de usar o que é realidade ele fazer
coisas a somar e conviver com a
realidade ele como pai
confesso que fiquei um pouco frustrado
com a certeza de que é um caminho sem
volta
isso é um caminho sem volta a maior
prova disso é que semana passada minha
filha de 5 anos e chamou de seu pai
o painel sabe o que é cortar
eu e surpresa eu acho que sabe que a
portagem é porque é só para garantir o
presente de natal porque sendo que era
um jogo importante esse tipo de
comportamento nada mais é do que um a
inovação tem trazido nos últimos anos e
usar e dizer que não é um processo de
evolução e se o processo de revolução o
quanto de tempo e todas essas
transformações acontecer
eu sou do mundo na era analógica era do
manual de instrução
nos últimos 20 anos vivemos a
transformação causada pelo fato da
internet nas nossas casas
vivi toda essa transição e sendo o mundo
digital que como tudo que é novo a gente
tem um pouco de envolvimento e receio é
o fascínio e ver pessoas que estão
passando por inclusão digital tem a
aprender mas ficou envolver o meu medo
ou receio a isso e hoje nós vivemos no
que se trata de um código digital estão
ativos de nascer
talvez alguns colegas em comunidade nós
somos imigrantes nesse mundo onde ela é
meu logistas criado pela inovação que
hoje em tempo de entender nada
assim como ninguém explicar as coisas
devem ser mais possível princípio esse
processo de inovação um novo tipo de
desenvolvimento de conhecimento é o fato
de podermos desenvolver mais ainda nossa
inteligência cognitiva
isso é um processo essa inteligência
cognitiva traz consigo as coisas - uma
provocação para vocês e que vocês
aprenderam os dias
se você aprender um novo tratamento
estatístico trabalhar com nada do
processo de extração entre as coisas são
rápidas e muito mais coisas em menos
tempo se você passar hoje 7 de nada pela
informação que a gente recebe dois anos
nos últimos 15 anos os jovens
empreendedores o abrir e questionamentos
a eles porque eles ligados diretamente
ao que é novo e positivo porque ninguém
tem mais tempo de entender nada de
explicar isso eu quero levar para o
mundo dos negócios e com esses novos
negócios e que a interatividade como foi
proposta de valor ou seja as novas
empresas através de novos mercados gera
novos comportamentos e novos negócios
inovadores e vou ter que mostrar o seu
produto para as pessoas e não ser
tratado apenas com produtos
diferenciados mais produtos
diferenciadores produtos que
intuitivamente faz com que qualquer
consumidor perceba que aquele produto
foi feito exclusivamente para ele o que
gerou algum tipo de diferenciação e ou a
empresa criou entregou e capturou valor
que eu percebi naquilo ela que vende
aquele serviço ela está comigo tratando
o povo dando continuidade a esse assunto
a primeira coisa que vem à cabeça de
vocês e que vocês vêem essa frase quando
você
vou ler 60% dos convites vendidos no
mundo sobre apenas três sabores
eu tenho certeza que vocês aqui 70%
época sequer chorando neste momento
quais são os sabores horas até 225 você
deve estar pensando nunca na minha vida
então abrimos o referido negócio muito
limitado 60% de todo tipo de transação
vai rolar em cima de três produtos e
talvez 5 é bastante e já pensando
preciso abrir urgentemente uma
sorveteria o que cada um negócio muito
bom todo o mercado vai girar em cima de
três produtos eu sei que todo mundo vai
ter os mesmos três produtos coren é a
maneira que eu vou poder usar os três
produtos de forma inovadora e atrair
todo que o cliente vai entender isso com
uma grande diferença pra ele
os 40% de venda de um jeito de ver
qualquer tipo sofrer qualquer tipo de
mudança para atrair esses três sabores
específicos e somente meus a minha cara
mas vou fazer isso a partir do momento
que eu entendo pra quem eu vou vender
esse sorvete que diferencia esse convite
e vai fazer de forma criativa e
imaginativa entender muito menos tempo
de explicar o que é mais importante usam
o produto ou serviço
a tecnologia ea experiência vai ser
diferenciador simples
é isso aí
nesse processo a gente tem que ter bem
então é que não se pode solucionar
problemas com o mesmo tipo de pensamento
isso é a base do processo salvador a
gerar diferença pra alguém levar essas
pessoas experiências distintas aquilo
que seria um lugar como esse tipo de
análise
há algum tempo atrás eu li esse software
chamado álbum que fala da modernidade
indica a percepção que estou fazendo
aqui colocando a sociedade como o
líquido e por conta da velocidade do
grande número de informações ela escorre
sobre os dois principais indicadores de
consistência que ele coloca o tempo eo
espaço ceder o lugar a coisas
extremamente o tempo cedeu o lugar a
ninguém mais tem tempo de explicar
e esse tempo e lugar a velocidade das
informações
o espaço é consistente é sólido é
concreto cedeu lugar à tecnologia e faz
com que a gente em qualquer lugar se
explicar
pensando nisso a puxar esse conceito ele
para a inovação
vamos aprender - abstraí temos aqui um
cenário de inovação inovação portanto
pode subir dois papéis o de livro onde
você pode inovar pra satisfazer as
necessidades a preencher lacunas o prazo
e formas diferenciadas
essa é a inovação por pendência é quando
o homem inventa porque é pedir mas o
homem é pedir inventa é a inovação
assumiu outro papel de recipiente
as pessoas passam inovar a poder ser a
as novas em seu estado em algum ponto
ela pode ser feita ou pendências ou por
tendência com 50 e gerar novas
necessidades o que a inovação gera
inovação acontece de forma isolada
veja o celular de vocês quando ela foi
criado ele foi criado por pendência era
passar nessa cidade era de que se
comunicar ao longo do tempo criando
novas inovações ao ponto e celular serve
pra tudo inclusive pra ligar mais caros
os melhores aplicativos aplicativos
momentos todo momento todos atualizados
crédito
self por exemplo sentido de isolá lo
desde quando me conheço por gente eu
conheci self
eu fiz muitas céus quando criança numa
lógica de filme kodak tem fotos na época
ele namorava um self é o self self
hoje você faz um software com a foto
vira conteúdo na selva então virou
conteúdo
isso é a perspectiva de que a inovação
ea inovação de forma isolada e nem de
forma linear
a questão é que ao longo do tempo sempre
um momento parte do princípio nós
nós queremos sempre satisfazer as
necessidade para viver em comunidade
inovação do seu estado líquido é o ser
humano buscam sempre as melhorias
independente que seja o fato do homem
inventar porque depende o depender do
que inventa
nós sempre buscamos satisfazer essas
necessidades
a melhor produção melhores processo para
melhor fonte de energia a melhor
comunicação
a diferença é que nesse mundo existe uma
grande quantidade de pessoas que todos
os dias vão buscar satisfazer suas
necessidades e um grupo muito pequeno de
pessoas que todos os dias estão tentando
entender como essas pessoas têm
necessidades para poder satisfazer as
essas pessoas ao longo do tempo e se no
estudo
considerei pessoas silenciosas começa
barulhentas e tenho certeza que nesse a
vitória está repleta esse barulho eu
considero como fator motivacional
o fator motivacional é uma parte da
ciência psicológica também
administrativo que fala que todos nós é
podemos receber os mesmos tipos mesmos
estímulos externos
mas a maneira que nós vamos responder a
esses estímulos
ela é inerente a cada um de nós por
conta da nossa personalidade
imagine que você está numa boate alguém
começa em cima do namorado não gostar
você começa a inchar e o resultado em
cima e você vai tirar satisfações qual é
que você vai revidar isso
eu correria desse tamanho aqui tem que
ser simpática rolar confusão mas tem
gente que ia revidar o sul tem gente que
iria chorar tem que ser rápido senão
leva a namorada queria mesmo por levar o
elevado estava mesmo a fim de que a
formação da personalidade
esse é o fator motivacional as pessoas
que têm esse barulho como fator
motivacional
esse barulho ele passa a alimentar a
essas pessoas e faz com que elas
consigam ou tenham visões das pessoas ao
redor não consegue ter
ela começa a enxergar coisa que outras
pessoas diz o seguinte é fixa em juízo
simplesmente da idéia de louco
esquizofrênico pessoas enxergam coisas
não consegue enxergar fazendo aquilo que
sempre sonhara realmente empreender
presidente sônia e foi a partir disso
nessa relação é com um pouco de loucura
talvez uma pitada de talento uma
overdose nessa loucura que eu entendi
que de empreendedor louco todo mundo tem
um pouco pra isso há um ano e meio atrás
eu escrevi um livro lancei o livro que é
gratuito e está disponível neste site
www shopping
é é um shopping é o tratamento para o
surto empreendedor
a idéia é perceber um pouco de si essa
característica desse fator motivacional
de insanidade que existe o comportamento
do empreendedor movido pela idéia capaz
de ser força motriz também na tecnologia
da persistência e no meu livro trata
essa insanidade com uma empresa ou
frente o que faz com que todo mundo seja
um pouco louco e um pouco empreendedor
choque é uma crônica de conhecimento
habilidade e operacionalidade e
qualidade e conformidade atividade
eu tenho certeza que nesse auditório
também um pouco de gente um pouco de
insanidade gente que está aqui com
idéias de inovar de criar novos negócios
novos mercados novos comportamentos
novos negócios inovadores com vida um
pouco esse tratamento para você colocar
esse prática você tem que conhecer ao
máximo
é o mercado que você quer atuar aqui
você vai fazer negócio porque como é que
ele vai entender o mercado
quando você passa a conhecer então sobre
a tua ideia você vai ter que ter
habilidade de trabalhar com pessoas
porque o empreendedor é o único sujeito
que consegue levar às pessoas onde
jamais aconteceriam sozinhas a
habilidade de trabalhar em equipe de
compartilhar informação
quando se consegue fazer isso você seja
com a equipe vai operacionalizar o teu o
teu negócio vai desenhar como é que vai
funcionar desde a estrutura até o
momento em que você vai ter o primeiro
contato com seu público
quando você fizer isso você vai entender
quanto você vai precisar para gerar o
mínimo de qualidade possível para alguém
dotar diferença o que o negócio passa a
ser diferenciador através da
interatividade vai ser diferenciador
próton quanto você vai precisar pra isso
depois você vai uniformizar tudo isso
criar estratégias trabalhar com
inteligência o fim colocar o bloco na
rua e ser efetivo trabalhar diretamente
com esse público e fazer com que eles
entendam que todo e qualquer negócio é
na verdade uma linha tênue
entre desempenho expectativas todo o
negócio promete alguns desempenho e
todos nós consumidores
criamos expectativas se você compra
acaba de fazer uma compra no site
aparece a mensagem este produto chegará
em sua residência no prazo máximo de
seis dias e seu desempenho a empresa
promete enquanto a expectativa é que ele
chega para ser vice
se não chegar você vai ficar o que 76
desconfiado se chegar satisfeito
confiante
se você sai da minha palestra com dor de
cabeça
a nossa palestra com dor de cabeça na
primeira farmácia tinha informações que
só eu quero um remédio para dor de
cabeça
o cara vai te dizer que eu estou mas sei
que ele vai passar dez minutos só que já
passaram 10 milhões já passaram 18 de
cabeça não passou então o desempenho
fica muito distante da expectativa e
isso me causa em insatisfação e isso me
causa desconfiança
percebo esse gráfico e leve para a vida
de vocês como pais como educadores com
patrões como empregados como alunos como
pessoas
a vida está sempre esse processo que a
gente precisa desempenhar porque alguém
gera expectativa e pra gente poder
conviver é muito necessário que exista
satisfação e confiança isso é
comportamento
isso é empreendedorismo
isso é o fato de você construir todo
tipo de novo conhecimento capaz de
aplicar nessas idéias que vocês estão
enlouquecendo aí ficando em sanos com
ela e transformá-los em negócios
faça isso e apliques uma coisa que muita
gente quer mas lembre se faça isso com
interatividade e inovação e unidade
foi uma honra e um prazer obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]